one of the problems with symbolism is
that when you hear people Simba making
symbolic interpretations for the first
time those people can often feel like
they're jumping all over the place and
sometimes some people that's what
happens but for those that really
understand the patterns that underlie
things what can sometimes seem like
strange jumps are in fact a very tight
and coherent web of meanings and
analogies and and these analogies are
built out of the extremely dense origin
of something and then they take on a
more and more explicit form as the grand
story if you will unfolds so in terms of
Christianity the pattern begins in
Genesis and then unfolds finding its
highest and most complete internalized
version in the person of Christ and in
the end these patterns are really the
underlying patterns of reality and they
they find there let's say they they find
form in particular instances in
particular forms and there that there
really are the pattern that link
consciousness to phenomena and map out
the world as it presents itself to us so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to to
follow one golden thread if you will I'm
gonna try to unpack one thread for you
it's going to be a low-resolution
version but it maybe it'll help you to
see how things can follow from the
beginning and develop so we're going to
start in Genesis 1
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the earth now the earth was formless
and empty darkness was over the surface
of the deep and the Spirit of God was
hovering over the waters and God said
let there be light and there was light
God saw that the light was good and he
separated the light from the darkness
so notice there's a very deep pattern
which is set up right away first of all
there are these two opposites heaven and
earth they're really the two first poles
the extremes of creation we could say
the earth is described first chaos
emptiness darkness and this notion of
the deep and all of these are below we
could say and then above is the spirit
the wind of God which is related to
heaven but then there also is the first
word and that word is for there to be
light so you can see above wind spirit
heaven but also word identity name right
light as the prerequisite for vision
clarity it's all of these are these
these notions of identity and meaning
are related together together and and
together both a heaven and earth they
give us a very powerful set of analogies
by which to view things like I said at
the beginning of course there there is
more subtlety here but the level of
resolution I'm going to take is going to
be sufficient for you to at least
perceive the pattern it's important to
notice that darkness which will be in a
way associated with below with
potentiality proceeds light okay and in
a way it is an extension of the chaos of
the void right of that potentiality of
creation this helps us to understand
what might seem like the the stranger
aspects of some of the other days the
teaming up of opposites with with the
stating of what is below first and then
what is above as if what is we state
potential
first the question the frame you know
the the potentiality and then comes
light comes word comes an answer to to
manifest that potentiality okay so in
terms of space we see that on the third
day for example there's this pulling of
dry land out of the waters right and
then there's vegetation so you can
imagine it you know like the this lower
waters as a kind of bottomless chaos
right the deep and then the land itself
as being slightly higher right coming
out of that watery chaos and then
immediately on top of that is the
vegetation of this land okay but then
right away on the fourth day after the
creation of this of pulling up the land
in making the vegetation there is the
creation of the heavenly bodies okay so
you can see again the opposite relation
being repeated what is heaven and earth
and then a bit higher this solid earth
of vegetation then a bit lower the idea
of the heavenly bodies okay I mean
scientifically of course this makes
absolutely no sense okay and it's not as
if early Christians didn't know this
origin for example pointed this out in
the 3rd century right in scientific
terms obviously vegetation does not come
before the Sun or the moon it is a
pattern of being ok then on the fifth
day fish are created so the lowest form
of life lowest in terms of
phenomenological place right and then on
the same day after the fish the birds
are created above as the highest form of
life closest to the heaven and in a way
related to heaven right so this day will
give us a key to understanding this
notion of fish as this as the lowest
life or life hiding in chaos life hiding
in the outer darkness ok and this is why
this image of Christ as a fisherman or
the the church as as fishermen who put
their nets out into darkness and pull in
you know the lost sparks of life that
are hiding in the the void and the chaos
okay and then the birds will play
spiritual roles in many stories and will
will represent let's say the influence
of heaven in those stories then finally
there is man on the sixth day and man
unites the earth with heaven itself
contains them as masculine and feminine
the two opposites within himself
we also learn in the next chapter of how
man not only reproduces in himself the
cosmic duality but ultimately acts as a
union of heaven and earth because the
breath the Spirit of God right the
Spirit which which was over the surface
of the deep on the first day now enters
into the earth as God blows into Adam's
nostrils after fashioning him out of the
dust in his own image okay so we have
this basic pattern once again we
realized that this is not a scientific
description but rather an ontological
hierarchy okay heaven earth birds you
know all of this is described as a
hierarchy with man in the middle as this
microcosm the anchor of creation who
holds heaven meaning light spirit
together with earth chaos potentiality
and darkness right within himself now
versions of this pattern will be
repeated in several places in the Bible
in different ways and with different
variations but if one pays attention one
can see it quite clearly first when the
world falls apart during the time of
Noah this is shown as a return to the
primordial state at the beginning where
all is swallowed up by the chaotic
waters and heaven and earth are
completely separated once again here we
also begin to see the the intuitive
relationship between a descent into the
chaotic waters and death right as the
whole world and all life outside the ark
vanishes into the flood in this story of
Noah also you can see this notion of
mixture as moving towards chaos
so you can imagine the world as related
to a center and identity okay and then
chaos potential is seen as on the edge
on the outside of the world world the
chaos of death will also be associated
with the notion of what is foreign okay
and so the foreign that which is outside
our identity whatever that is can often
act as a proxy for what is unknown right
what is Uncharted in chaotic and this
you'll find in stories not only in the
Bible but in stories all over the world
this idea can be shown in terms of us
kind of sacred geography that can help
us to understand it so for example there
are many ancient traditions and you can
find these traditions for example in the
the hymns of paradise bites by Saint
Ephrem the Syrian this is a book that I
recommend highly by the way a lot of
people have been asking me for a reading
lists yeah and they're coming don't
worry I'm get to it at some point but
this book for sure is some somewhat a
book that anybody who's interested in
Christian symbolism should read the
hymns of paradise by Saint Ephrem the
Syrian and read the introduction to it's
very good okay so there's this sacred
geography the garden is is set up as a
mountain with the Tree of Life at the
summit of the mountain and a bit further
down we have the tree of knowledge of
good and evil and then lower still we
have the wall around the garden with the
cherub which protects that wall with
with the flaming sword okay and so we
can see that the fall of man is a
descent of the mountain as Animus chased
out of the garden he goes down the
mountain and so for example in Saint
Ephrem vision interpretation when Cain
tells Abel let us go to the plain so he
says this to Abel just before he kills
him the idea is that he's saying not
just let us go to the plain but let us
go to the valley right to the low point
right and that's where Cain kills Abel
so there's tradition we'll show this
this this geography is geographic
descent to exemplify the
the acceleration of the fall and so for
example I get once again in the story of
the flood where the sons of God go into
the daughters of men and this mixture
causes these crazy chaotic Giants in
Saint Ephrem description of it to help
us understand what that means he
envisions the sons of God as living
higher up on the mountain of the cosmos
let's say and the daughters of men
living lower on the mountain closer to
the ocean closer to the waters of chaos
and in the flood story for example he'll
say things like the waters of the flood
covered the entire world but they never
reached the gates of the Garden of Eden
which remained above the world okay so
you can kind of understand what that can
mean in terms of this ontological
hierarchy now in the flood story we find
the first pattern of creation repeated
so as the world is covered with water
Noah sends a dove a bird representing
heaven to fly down and find land within
the chaotic waters participating in
recreating the world after the flood so
early Christians took advantage of this
relationship between the waters and
death and for example we can see in the
catacombs that the Noah's Ark
represented as a kind of Sark
sarcophagus in the Roman catacombs so
you can see also the waters become the
fish it's on the same catacombs you'll
have an image of Noah in his argument
you'll have an image of Jonah in the
fish and the fish is really this this
sea monster this great sea monster and
the mouth of the sea monster for example
taken from the story of Jonah will
become an image of the mouth of hell in
later Western Christian tradition and
even in some Eastern examples we found
this mouth of the monster as related to
death and we see it at the bottom of the
of the ladder of the divine ascendant so
the ladder of the divine ascent is the
same as the mountain is this ascent of
an ontological hierarchy and at the
bottom will find this mouth of the
monster as
mouth of death okay so always keep in
mind first of all that you know the
original pattern that I that I told you
of the waters with the Spirit of God and
our in a way the Spirit of God descends
to create the world okay we see a very
pristine example of this when the
Israelites come to the Red Sea with
Moses and by Moses his action a great
wind right and always remember that
those spirit and wind in in English and
in our languages are separate in ancient
languages they were the same and so the
the Israelites faced death at the Red
Sea at the hand of the foreigners the
foreign Egyptians and the wind from the
east blows open the sea and reveals dry
land
so this wind from the from the east you
also have to understand it as a wind
coming from the origin remember that
Eden is placed in the east okay and so
you can imagine the East as the
beginning the origin we see it in the
sense of the the raising of the Sun so
this wind coming from the you can
imagine it's coming like from the top of
the mountain and coming down and opening
the the seal its and revealing the land
so that the Israelites can cross okay
and so the Israelites passed with the
waters and the Egyptians get caught in
the chaos the waters cover them like the
flood covered the corrupt world in the
story of Noah so you can see this
emerging you can see emerging this
general notion that's sinking into the
water sinking into to mire for example
to the moderate to the waters into the
deep right they're descending into earth
you know and how this is related to
death you know I mean it's obvious
because we bury the dead but in terms of
a more understanding the ontological
hierarchy as it as in death is a is a
coming down the mountain and fragmenting
from the one to the many that's what
decomposition is and so descending into
the ocean or descending into waters and
to dart into into the pit but also we
also see how all of this is related to
the idea of the foreigner as a marker of
death
okay so the basic pattern what happens
is it gets multiplied into all these
different examples as if to show us
different facets of this basic pattern
for example Joseph gets descended into a
sister right so to then go to the land
of the foreigner Daniel the prophet
Daniel is descended into this cavern
this lion's den where the monsters are
by a foreign King Jonah is thrown into
the waters by foreign sailors going down
into the waters and facing the sea
monster okay so the pattern is the same
but it plays out differently but there's
also a duality which gets set up in
which the foreigner is both an image of
chaos but also becomes an image of
resurrection now notice for example how
Joseph goes into the cistern to be sold
to the Egyptians okay but then his
travel into Egypt is what will
ultimately save his family from
starvation there's another even more
explicit version of this where the
Prophet Jeremy gets put into a cistern
like like a prison and then he's pulled
out of the cistern by an Ethiopian man
you know in the biblical tradition the
Ethiopian is the ultimate foreigner
let's say because he's so far away from
our perceptions of our understanding and
so the the Ethiopian man pulls him out
of the cistern using these decaying
rotting rags okay so you can't it's
difficult to be more explicit than that
and this pattern of death saving us from
death with the Orthodox called trampling
on death by death is very important and
I won't emphasize that too much today
but I just want you to notice that it's
there and that it's important and then
hopefully I can explain it in a later
video so as to the main pattern I'm
trying to show you there are plenty of
other micro examples where this gets
repeated and I don't want to go into all
of them
there's the crossing of the Jordan by
the Israelites the crossing of Elijah of
the Jordan
then there's Elijah's axe
you know which rises up and floats at
the top of the waters being raised as
Earth from the sea so there's a plenty
of examples but I want you to notice
this this example in the songs is a very
powerful song which kind of pulls these
things together it's in Psalm 69 it says
save me O God for the waters are come in
unto my soul I sink in the deep mire
where there is no standing I am coming
to the deep waters where the floods
overflow me I am become a stranger unto
my brethren and an alien unto my
mother's children deliver me out of the
mire and let me not sink let me be
delivered from them that hate me and out
of the deep waters let not the water
flood overflow me neither let the deep
swallow me up and let not the pit shut
her mouth upon me okay so notice how
he's sinking into the mire you know down
into the deep waters into the flood is
akin to dying is it came to be swallowed
by a mouth swallowed by a monster like
in the story of Jonah for example is it
descending into a pit kind of descending
into the earth not just in the water but
into the earth but it's also becoming a
stranger becoming an alien to his own
people okay so all of those images that
I that I've been trying to show you
they're all strung up in a very
beautiful pattern now what I mostly want
to show you is how all of this then
comes together in the story of Christ
okay there are several examples I could
use but one of the clearest seems to be
the story of Christ's baptism in the
Gospel of st. Matthew it is very very
powerfully described as this as after
crisis didn't baptize it says as soon as
Jesus was baptized he went up out of the
water at that moment heaven was opened
and he saw the Spirit of God as
descending like a dove and alighting on
him and a voice from heaven said this is
my son whom I love
with with him I am well pleased so
hopefully by now for most of it it will
be pretty clear that this image repeats
the Genesis creation story water below
have an above which opens up and the
spirit the wind the the Spirit of God
descends in the shape of a bird like in
the story of Noah and the voice of God
is heard from the heaven right now let
there be light let there be of the
beginning is there the spirit and the
waters okay and Christ appears as a kind
of bridge which unites heaven and earth
you have to see it kind of like in the
traditional icon of the baptism of
Christ with Christ's feet in the water
is the bottom of his body in the water
and his head up above with the Dove
coming down and in the traditional icon
to emphasize that even more the way the
jordan river is is displayed suggests a
cave as well right so as so so we can
understand that baptism is really a
descent into the earth a descent into
death and into chaos there are even
versions of the baptism icon where
Christ is shown standing on the doors of
the abyss the doors of Hades and
crushing these snakes which are at the
bottom of the world okay and so the
image of the baptism is really a cosmic
image it becomes an image of the
Incarnation itself of how heaven and
earth have come together now I've been
fully United but at least in the
Orthodox spirit it's also a vision of
how the entire creation mysteriously
participates in the Incarnation somehow
how all of creation can be a symbol of
divinity so one of the things that
appears in the icon if you look at the
bottom of the icons you have these
strange little creatures that are
fleeing you know the feet of Christ and
some of the icons you'll see this and
from a psalm which talks about the
Jordan turning away and the you know the
sea receding from from the presence of
God and so this idea that Christ
descends in the waters and these these
these these images of the the Jordan and
the sea are fleeing him but what's
interesting in terms of symbolism is
that the way they're represented in the
icon they're represented in the guise of
these ancient gods like these ancient
river gods and so you can also see it as
let's say the ancient gods or the
foreign gods fleeing the presence of you
know the the of Christ as he comes down
into the water ok so there's also this
idea of the of the foreign being being
cast you know kind of falling away in
this in this image another image of that
is also in the icon you'll see there's
an axe on a tree and that has to do with
them the words of Saint John the Baptist
who said the axe is at the root of the
tree and the idea is that baptism is
also this pruning of all the things that
don't bear fruit and so going down into
death down into chaos is finding the
essence the origin you know the thing
that binds you together and also pruning
and getting and cleaning off you know
all the things which are super
superfluous in' and not part of of
what's really what you are ok so you
come out of baptism as has purified
alright so that that that's all of that
is in that image but let's say in a
larger idea this idea of all of creation
participating in this process so for
example on the day of theophany which is
the day on the the calendar of the
church where we celebrate the baptism of
Christ it's also the day where the
waters of the world are blessed and so
all over the world processions will go
out to large bodies of water and the
priests will often throw a cross into
the water in order to an away show but
not just so but in a way participate in
how all of this is related together the
creation of the world the Incarnation
baptism all of these are like an
interwoven web of meanings and actions
which point to the mysterious way in
which the universe is full of the
infinite okay full of the mystery of
being as well and in the service of
theophany we hear a return in the words
of the service we hear a return on some
of the patterns that I mentioned here so
we hear phrases like you are our God who
drowned sin in the waters at the time of
Noah you are our God who in the sea and
at the hand of Moses delivered the
Hebrews from the bondage of Pharaoh
right and so you can see how there's
this interlocking these these
interlocking threads of references
coming together so then when you read
certain other texts in the Bible the
pattern reappears over and over again so
imagine now for example Christ walking
on the waters that you can see what that
can mean now walking on chaos mastering
the chaos of the deep and then Saint
Peter who starts to sink as he's walking
out on the waters with him and he cries
out like the psalmist saved me Oh Lord
I'm sinking into the mire I'm sinking
into the deep and then Christ reaches in
and pulls out st. Peter as an image of
how we can be pulled out of our own
passions our own desires our own chaos
but also he's pulling out Peter the
stone Peter means stone he's pulling out
the foundation of the church he's
creating the church as he's pulling
Peter and repeating the same image that
is there from the beginning in in in
Genesis of pulling the earth out of the
sea and establishing something solid on
which we can live okay and so all these
images come together but let's say in
terms of just interpreting a verse which
sometimes might seem obscure for example
in in the Epistle of st. Peter he talks
about baptism and then he talked about
baptism he centers it around Christ and
so he
about Christ he was put to death in the
body but made alive in the spirit in
which he also went and preached to the
spirits in prison who disobeyed long ago
when God waited patiently in the days of
Noah while the ark was being built in
the ark a few people only eight souls
were saved through the water and this
water symbolizes the baptism that now
saves you now if you would read that at
first glance you would find it very odd
to see all those things put together you
know this idea of death and resurrection
and then in the time of Noah and these
Giants in the time of Noah but now when
you start to see the pattern you see it
happen again I was put to death in the
body that was the earth but made alive
in the spirit there is heaven the basic
first structure from the beginning okay
and then he also went down and preached
to the spirits in prison preached to the
fish preached to the to the the sparks
of light which are hidden in the chaos
you know and pulled them up pulled them
up like a fisherman pulls out the fish
okay and then he relates it to the flood
like we've been doing since the
beginning and this idea of the spirits
that were lost in the time of the flood
and then the flood is related to baptism
you know so all of those things just
kind of come together and interlock in a
beautiful and very powerful way okay and
so you can see as this idea Christ goes
down into the into the the the waters
goes down into death goes down to find
the spirits that are down there in the
bottom and you can see in your mind you
know Jonah coming out of the fish you
can see Joseph coming out of this
cistern you can see Jeremy coming out of
his system as well you can see the
psalmist getting pulled out of the
waters okay all of this is completely
coherent now this is really just a very
very tiny thread okay and in a way I
just wanted to kind of pull this thread
out and show you and simplify things to
a greater degree but hopefully you can
see just the beginning of these patterns
they're in Scripture and they're in
tradition and how they really can create
a system of symbols by which we can act
in a system of symbols that which we can
use society and the world and our place
in it so I hope it was helpful and I'll
see you soon
all right guys a lot of things have been
happening in the past month let's say or
past you know few few months I was in
Seattle I was in Vancouver with jordan
peterson and we did a few venues there
things have been kind of moving faster
and faster i've been now appearing on a
lot of youtube channels on podcasts i
was on I'm trying to put a few clips on
my channel but I can't keep up so I'm
not gonna put clips of all these these
discussions I was on the joint Peterson
interviewed me for his channel again
recently I was on the sorting myself out
YouTube channel the distributist and
there's been quite a few so look it up
on on on the Ute on youtube search or
else follow me on social media I try to
put put it up at least on Facebook and
on Twitter for people to know where I'm
at and what's happening and so it's been
exciting there's been a lot of people
have been kind of rallying around me and
helping me out with patreon and it's
been exciting I just want to tell people
that I have two patreon accounts one is
for a drawing project that I'm involved
in and one is for these videos and I've
seen a lot of people kind of giving
either to one or the other so I'm not
sure I just want to make sure that
people know that if you give to the
drawing project I'm happy that you are
but it's going to kind of pull me in
that direction where I'm going to spend
more time on that if you give to the
video project then then that's kind of
what's going to be pulling my time in
that direction so but it's really
exciting to see everybody come together
um I want to give a few shout outs to
some people people have been really
amazing trying to help me out there's a
man his name is Nathan Meffert he he
interviewed me for his podcast but he's
been really helping me been helping me
out with understanding marketing and the
SEO stuff you know the different
keywords and helping me find ways to to
to brand the channel better and
everything so that's been awesome
there's also been a crazy thing that
happened you know I told you guys that
my YouTube comments were deleted by you
too
and then this man his name is Joe amber
Locke wrote me and he said I have your
comments and he had saved for some
reason he had saved my comments you know
in a Word document so he sent me these
comments and I have them now when I have
some time hopefully I can go back and
try to to put them back that at least
the important ones and so it's really
touching for me now with almost I was in
tears when I when I read that I couldn't
believe that someone would have taken
the time to do that you know just in
case so it's yeah it's been really crazy
there's a lot of stuff coming I'm
excited to read all your comments to
read all their messages you're sending
me I've got more movie analysis coming
up and and I'm going to start to take on
more of the kind of new atheist
arguments as well so there's a lot of
stuff in the works and I'm just excited
to have you guys along and keep
commenting keep sending me stuff gets me
revved up